[Music]
and this is a breakthrough role for you
jack because
an american accent
yes yes i was doing an american accent
what in that clip yes olivia
he was
it was good thank you very much
you see what a lot of actors do when
they do an american accent
is they tend to just go for like one
region of america and they commit to a
single american accent i decided with
this role that i would take soniter
around all 50 states
sometimes in the same scene i thought
why just do one when you can show off
them all
so i would start the scene talking like
i was from new york and then all of a
sudden i'm suddenly speaking like i'm a
cali girl and by the end of the scene
they're stopping me because it sounds
like i'm from the dukes of hazard i'm
all over the place but i thought you
know just show off your skills
[Music]